here we go
[Applause]
we want to make this lady go that's what
we want that's great coaching that make
them call it time every go
thank you so much Maggie the message
rates Kyra's income the game presented
by Jordan Brown check that out straight
double behind the back of it finds Devon
Knox with the easy floods tre Young's
having himself a game here fellas
Trey young as
we're under 7 minutes remaining we gotta
get some decent stuff right now
[Applause]
hot sister s crisscross butt squeeze
look at this one
the left to the right said let me snatch
a batch real quick
through the legs watch the bench to
loosen their minds if they'll just
discard something because
Oh
[Music]
swatted at the other end by the cherry
pickle jeez cherry pit oh gee
[Applause]
Wow
so Trey Young has now dribble between
two guys legs Jascha Kogi and DeAndre in
today's game second one four five so
Trey Young has now dribble between two
guys legs Jascha Kogi and DeAndre in
today's game second one for a buck